[Music]
we all know how crazy Tom Cruise is
right
he's crazy Oh kind of crazy I've been on
our way about to say yes he can find
more chairs no Scientology
nope he's passed that crazy yeah he's
collabing with Tesla NASA wait so he has
had discussions is what it's being
reported about shooting a film at the
International Space Station oh it's a
film yeah that was like a collab collab
oh he has his hands in it you know well
he does yeah I mean yes he's like the
conversation science not like just
filming in a scientific area hold on
instead of a plane this time he's gonna
hold on to a shuttle and he's gonna
learn how to fly the space shuttle
himself
I want to see him going to know cuz he
does everything well he's also a master
skydiver so he's out of all the actors
he's the most prepared to film yeah he's
a pilot he flew that helicopter himself
for the movie well shut down did he
really fly those planes in Top Gun I
don't think that's the time cruise we
know now yet Oh such a cool airplane
[ __ ] but the f-14s or whatever's the 15s
yeah they did mention that he has worked
with the government in the past to
create films like for example for Top
Gun soundtrack ever the US may be helped
in the making of both oh I heard a lot
of times the government works like if
you're gonna show off anything with
military they want you to do it like
properly or this way or like the
brand-new deal it's a brand yeah they
complete have to go by their rules
because they also don't want to talk
[ __ ] about the other so they're very in
it so they're like if you do this will
fund it will get you the the props will
get you actual things to use in your
thing and they supply actual military
like jazz everything you'd be on the
thing but you have to show American in a
positive way I wonder if they were also
a part of the song highway to the
dangerzone
and in there they are making adjustments
like uh you know can we
say something cooler like danger like
maybe they were saying caution zone or
some [ __ ] well yeah so they're saying
that NASA has this growing interest in
finding additional commercial ventures
for the space program especially during
so useless administration the Trump
administration what do you say NASA so
useless now they do a lot of crazy [ __ ]
they just post pass I mean all I know is
they got that thing on Mars taking
majors on the Red Rocks within like two
weeks they made what they made math big
mass produced ventilators cuz we were in
need of it so they got like n 100 really
fast yeah cuz my girlfriend she she
works with NASA and then out of nowhere
she was like oh yeah I have to go in so
to do like inventory so we can make
these ventilators really fast and they
finished in what nine days or something
cuz they're not doing anything that's
why they last time we went to the moon
man I like how the Air Force put out the
UFO videos before NASA I know they
should be the first one with all that
footage the Air Force man they don't
even break that [ __ ] barrier NASA
keeps going out they should be the
closest to the aliens damn I still
haven't seen that footage I have it just
looks like an ant moving across the
screen yeah but they they released it
though cuz they're probably trying to
distract us from the something else okay
push out of windows a lot yeah doctors
getting pushed out of windows
yeah so they are mentioning that no
studio has gotten involved yet in this
project I know please ask christopher
nolan's indirectly Oh Tom Cruise find
his own Chris manola know what this
[ __ ] IMAX [ __ ] up in outer space you
[ __ ] kidding me yeah why not could
probably make something better on earth
with the technology that we have because
in space you're gonna have to deal with
so much more the space the money and
that's the fun part for you guys yeah
looking at all like the zero-gravity
like things that you just can't do porn
porn in space would be probably yeah
they're a gravity porn I think the one
with the plane that goes they become
shot and it need hits him and it goes in
every direction oh [ __ ]
do you know what they need is they need
a Tim Burton to do a space movie with
Tom Cruise really really dark looking I
just don't like his movies that much
what Johnny Depp have to be in it I know
using Johnny Darrow and and and not is
it his wife yeah yeah ba Tarantino cuz
his next film wants to be in space okay
I thought he does one more he has one
more he'd better come out with one more
because they retired once upon a time
suck dick yeah another one Tarantino
space film would be the worst you have
two people floating there and having
dialogues like ten minutes straight
he'll probably have uma Thurman [ __ ] up
Jamie Foxx or something inside inside
the space shuttle he'll put all his
characters all in one movie interface
he's gonna have like Christopher Walken
as Yoda or whatever I don't know
Tobit on film but there's like film
school is going everywhere like and then
all the fake blood like splashing like
in like little beads imagine resetting
the scene I mean this is getting light
into a movie like production be like you
know how you have to clean up and reset
it like for black one cleaning of
[ __ ] no gravity of blood work I
wouldn't want a PA that say no what
would they actually do besides the zero
G's [ __ ] right to think about it no but
I'm like what so that's why we're all
sitting here at Jake and Tom Cruise is a
negotiating [ __ ] with NASA yeah well
what the film production look like as
you mentioned PA and I'm like imagine
being a PA and [ __ ] ISS just be
excited cuz I've seen those videos from
the actual space station like those
scientists they have smallest windows
yeah look outside really yeah I didn't
have a Christopher Nolan out there to
help him shoot that footage either out
that small window the dialogue
everyone's gonna be by the window
significant way to make an exam a but if
I was just floating though outside of
the ISS I'd be cool Evans inside suits
then you have all the space you want you
have to clean up things just fly away me
would be crazy cuz there are times when
the guys have to come out and they have
to help fix the space and stuff yeah the
spacewalks are like really rare I wonder
if it's considered littering if you
throw [ __ ] outside of yours John they
always eject stuff out there for like
diapers like space diapers like I feel
like I don't know cuz it's like they had
the actual footage from like the space
spacewalk and stuff but that's probably
doesn't look as cool especially old but
then we have like interstellar what was
the one that the extra so yeah was it
Astro like all of them Luke dopest [ __ ]
you want a shot in space though right
this will be even no perfect shot it's
big and also I think all those movies
always gave going to outer space a bad
rep like like it's like oh it's not
nicely it's a scary right again man I
was wanting the commercials answers
they're like I want to promote a healthy
relationship with going into outer space
so they're probably gonna make it like I
don't know happy yeah I wanted well he
did well
be an action action movie for sure
action movie yeah in space like SpaceX
knows how to make things like Elon Musk
knows that like design comes first that
[ __ ] looks crazy mom as a fashion model
so why is it that when a designer
someone doesn't get behind something
when we do have technology and it comes
out it looks like I want to crush it cuz
a nerd made it my Angelyn functionality
the Android stuff yeah like Android
stuff like NASA stuff like I remember
our school did like a solar car like
competition and they had all these solar
robots and I sat there watching the race
wanting to step on every single one of
those [ __ ] because it looked like
some [ __ ] is it or is it something in
my soul that goes why couldn't you
design something that looked awesome you
know you're sounding like those guys
that we just talked about that will go
out there and like kill and mentors
because they don't want to advance it or
whatever the [ __ ] really
I would be alright so NASA makes a 18
million dollars faces that NASA makes an
18 million dollar spacesuit right it's
big and bulky for functionality would
you do to improve it the style I'd sell
it go to Vegas he didn't say they were
giving it to you brought you on as a
designer so it's 18
make it look dope yeah well first off we
got to think of a theme right cuz high
right space pants awesome theme oh but
then they break it down it's white
because it needs to reflect the Sun so
you can see yourself out there I would
have been like white is [ __ ] wack
black we're gonna match the budget space
Morris [ __ ] costs or not assumes
though what is it they're in uniform
which just makes it fun is its craters
if you zoom in it's like moon from the
shoulder become a real life really real
life is like that too they have to have
a green green screen yeah I think that's
why the show improved it exactly the
show is showing it as like the moon
camouflage just me black with white dots
the stars retire there should be cheese
peppers I'm excited for that show that
me too comes out this month yeah this
month on what Amazon yes Oh May 20th I
think that's exam is on Netflix we will
show spaces Steve Carell the makers of
the office with Steve Pirelli sports
commentary and Phoebe is his wife from
friends yeah that's tiny sports because
that's is it us is it a joke on the
whole new exact to the military really
the project is soonest I think we're
doing the show you know what's a trip
though I wonder how much of this [ __ ] is
a way to control the public like they're
slowly releasing these UFO things and
there's like a whole like they're all in
on the take like like they're creating
the normal for us by representing in
television and movies yeah like or just
yeah or like the whole creation of the
space force he means of regional space
voice yeah although the the you know how
now they just released the air force
released footage on [ __ ] right so what
if those UFOs are just ours like
I don't know it's true mom we've had
this technology yeah we've had it and
then I don't know you know publicity
stunts
yeah Bob Lazar said that we've had this
[ __ ] technology for decades Bob Lazar
is probably watching this [ __ ] like told
you [ __ ] he's not gonna push on
Windows he's been alive this whole time
how is he not no windows the
government's like dudes pushed up the
first floor what do you think he's crazy
like reason why he hasn't been killed
because if he gets killed that just
further proves right yeah true
don't tell the Russians that Russia's
don't care and [ __ ] it just shut just
shut them up
[Music]
[Music]